we're going to talk about collaborative
table model for users and text so this
is a joint work with my advisor at
Princeton they'd be blind
um so and I'm now it by the way I lied
okay cool so here's our line so I'm
going to talk about first I'm going to
talk about a basics of topic modeling
just this is work okay then this
basically covers like what it what is
the topic model and what it can be what
you can be used for in an accident talk
about a collaborative topic models which
is a generalization of a basic top
humanity that simultaneously models
users behaviors and textured documents
so finally I'm going to show a small
demo that actually incorporate these
ideas in this collaborative models and
so you can how you can use it for
recommended scientific articles okay
great so next introduction to topic
modeling okay so we have lots of data
and sometimes or maybe most of time it's
not well organized so as a human beings
we do want to organize this data in some
way so that we can actually you know
oops right keep asking you join I spin
you Wi-Fi so basically you know Guiche
for example google search is an
excellent example of how to organize
your data they impact your data so that
when you need something from the
whatever the database or whatever there
are Google servers then you just take a
query and you guys something and they
will try to find the most relevant
things in on their end and then present
it to you that's very useful in but
sometimes there is kind of other kind of
like a task it's kind of can be
difficult for Google tune to finish to
actually you know to pretend useful ways
to you for example suppose that you you
know what you you want to study a
subject I say how to raise a good kid
you may just can say to certain
documents about this subject but you
know you know you can type some queries
to find something in it but the problem
is sometimes it's kind of really hard to
it's the email arbiter query so in this
case we may need some kind of tools that
actually help us to organize the data
and he gave us some kind of
summarization and also like how was to
find hidden patterns in the inside of
this data or maybe provide some other
ways to visualize this data so topic
modeling is actually kind of this tool
that can help us to organize this kind
of data say you want to study some kind
of a subject or maybe it's an origin
could be like you say you are a patent
attorney you want to study a patent and
your scope coach this parent surgery
that's fine like thousands of pattern
that related to this patent how do you
do with it so topic modeling is kind of
cool like that so that you can use it to
summarize data finding patterns and we
slide to data okay so that's the basic
euler what papi modeling can be used for
sorry about it okay
there were lots of work around the table
in modeling so here was some of my work
they give you some examples
so what comic moaning can be used for
okay so so here is we actually
generalize a topic model to help you
organize the types of document in some
kind of like a like tree based hierarchy
for example in the root node there is a
general concept they'll be extracted
from this data it's about government I
think and then if you go deeper into the
tray leaves you see more specific
concept about the government so there's
another example with image data that we
use a table model to make predictions on
class labels and annotations basic class
level can be can be thought as a steel
label and annotations can be you know
the objects in within this image so
certainly this is not the same Adar
anymore so this is a very far found they
have big far from actually very far from
it but it's an example that you can use
topic modeling for this kind of task
another example could be like a document
recommendation say you've got some usage
data with users reading history so we
can do some kind of like a document
recommendation for you know one
particular user or say you get the play
list or whatever you know this like
playlist for some users you can do like
music recommendations for that
particular year for example like if you
like content style you might like you
know some other songs by the same artist
that type of thing it's a final example
I saw it's like suppose you got some
kind of like network data you can use
like a topic you're modeling like model
it's not exactly a topic model but the
idea behind it it's very similar to
discover like overlapping communities
sorry about it I might just turn off a
wife I think where it's Wi-Fi I don't
see it anyway
let's keep it that so for example on the
left hand side you've got a co-author
network basically you know I wrote a
paper with some other people miserable
wrote another paper tomorrow tomorrow
seminar people another person and then
so this model helps you discover like
our Latino communities among these
authors for example if I I worked on
topic modeling before and now I work on
say deep learning and then I could
belong to two research communities and
those this models based on this network
data helped us discover these kind of
communities ok that finished the
examples okay here comes to a little bit
like in a more formal formulation what
is the top model okay so here there's
one basic assumption behind the top
model is a document can have multiple
topics so you know imagine topic suppose
that we have the world has three topics
so you know the yellow one and say that
the right one say a blue one and you
know so in a document say this document
is about like seeking lives
what is it can see that their genetic
and then this document have this talk
about these three topics so but they
don't submit three topics do not
necessarily have the same like
popularity within this document oh sorry
about it yeah I always forgot it so
basically a let me just repeat it so
suppose we have the world had three
topics and you want to you know write a
document with the three topics how do
you do it
so you basically assume that a document
has some kind of proportions over these
three topics but not necessarily the
same proportion for example in this
example you have the you know it will be
a higher proportion for that yellow
topic means this document talking it's
talking about this topic more than the
other two so that's basically the basic
assumption within a topic model so here
is a more kind of like I wouldn't say
it's a mathematical formulation it is a
more kind of like a
more formal formation what it what it's
like a hubba with you actually form a
model like this so here a little bit
like a little bit like a math here so
basically you know we use a graphical
model representation here
so basically beta the know the beta
represent a topic then the plate with
the number K represent how many hobbies
have in this model say we have three
topic than K 3 here then now it comes to
a document how do we model this document
we just talked about in the previous
slide is we use a copy proportion to
model this document basically say you
know we gotta stop your proportion for
this document when he says that this
document is talking about the green
topic which is over there more than our
two topics sorry I think I forgot what
is the one concept is here at a topic is
like a set of words which they co-occur
very often together so that when you put
them together and then sorry they mean
something like for human beings then
this actually represented by a
multinomial distribution or were your
vocabulary basic those words with high
probabilities they tend to occur
together in the same documents so you
know we now we get a dystopic
proportions for this document so but how
do we actually get this topic
proportions we're actually going to
actually go into this to the words in
this document and store like a color
each word with their public colors for
example if we have a higher proportion
for the green topic then we're going to
color a lot more words with with green
color than other words that's basically
you know how you how you think of how a
top model you know represent in your
mind so unfortunately those color will
not you know we're not there because
then you know the moment you get your
documents only the word you see so
there's a there's a process called
inference which actually you recover all
these colors and their words or
orderings given the
given the caisson of documents okay
so here's an example that we actually
run this inference on a 17,000 articles
from satellite basically will run a top
200 topic model 200 topping our da model
for this data set so this is that it has
one meeting one point saying meeting
words and you know just the size of our
Cabaret I started truncated to ake a
joinha
so these are the learning topics based
remember those colored topics and these
actually I shall learn the topics that
basically go ahead okay good thank you
so these are the words that actually
learn from those talk those set of
documents basically it means that for
example on the right hand side there's
the topic about classifier but that you
know the both words yeah actually the
labels I assigned to this topic they
don't the top model you know that's not
really generate a table for you but it
generate at least the words that tend to
co-occur together for example those
words those words learning machine
training vectors if you know the machine
learning then you know so this kind of
thing is about how train classifier if
you want to train classifier internal
you look for this type of words this
other other words are kind of similar
things from probability if you know this
kind of words you always use to to you
know to write something about heredity
and here is the copy of proportions for
example here's one document which is the
page rank citation ranking which is a
very popular very famous article so when
you analyze these type of proportions it
looks like it has you know higher
proposed table your proportions on those
blue topic and the red topic I'm sorry
the yeah the right topic yes so
basically it talks about like how you
ranked and document and talk about how
you do something like a back pages
things of that but it has a very low
copy of proportion for those the the
last topic you saw here you know maybe
it's not this document yesterday it's
not talking about this thing here's
another example it's a kind of famous
paper about how will you ask me the
parameter within a model with latent
variables so this this paper it seems to
be it seems to be you know focused on
particular how to do parameter
estimation so these the other two topics
list here all the relevant but they
don't really talk about it this is topic
so basically that's how you do you know
we get if you run a topping model that's
a very basic atopic model but there were
lots of generalization so this model so
you probably get a little bit more than
this if you actually you know use some
kind of like a more specific model than
this one okay so I think now we have the
basic knowledge to actually generalize
the basic FDA model to actually model
user behavior and attach documents okay
so I people read documents that's why
you know that's why the documents are
created for rate um but maybe not in the
future I'm not sure but right okay right
now like a people read documents so
specifically this application this model
is created for scientific articles but I
think it can be generalized to other
documents so that our data set or
applications but right now it seems this
kind of data that is for me is either
easier to get maybe some other data I
don't have access to so so we basically
look at the satellite data and monthly
data so this kind of like a two websites
provide like a web service so that you
can actually upload your like like
personal libraries that are you reading
histories to their website and so we
hope you use we hope to use this type of
data to actually you know to tell us how
people read documents you know you want
to be a document we say kind of go in
your mind it's not you don't just
randomly scan some documents for
whatever you know whatever reason you
want to read something that actually
interesting for you
so given this data we hope to you know
how people to find documents they are
interested in there were three goes here
but kind of like an is it's like it's
kind of vague here but I think we'll be
get clearer later on so and then we have
to learn what what dog will mean to
people who read them so you know for a
document I read it and the same document
you read it maybe you know we want to
get different
so and we also learned the behavior
people reading the documents and then
using these behaviors we can use for
like recommendations varied uncle so
here is basically the data we have it's
just like a screenshot from their
website for them this is one of the
users it has like 266 articles in his
library or in her library and then we
can use you know the data we want to be
we can use here is or I use here is the
title and abstract over these articles
there are a lot more information than
that suffering um of the author's its
documents and you know there are smaller
like where it's probably is the one
who's published but in this particular
model I just haven't had a chance to use
those kind of metadata which I which
actually I think will be very useful too
so this is just another example of
mandaleet data so it's pretty much
similar set up but they may have
different like other set of like of
functions on their website sorry about
it it's just keeps coming
um and it's okay so here is the basic
collaborative topic model by the way
feel free to ask any questions you have
so here is how it works so remember that
we have a you know the e/m paper i can
we just talked about in the beginning so
those two examples i saw are so here
this is one of those examples so if we
if we analyze the content of this
article we see that this article is
mostly about statistic concepts
basically you know this is for this is a
this sort for that topic which is about
more about a parameter estimation in
statistical models and you know suppose
we only have to group people like a
statistic ends the recent researchers so
giving this content of this article we
probably just want to recommend this
paper you know to two statistical people
which i think it's a kind of reasonable
because that's the
you're it but that's that's basically
the audience the author's paper walnuts
people probably on this paper to go
ahead so the basic idea so you know
they're they're one assumption in top
Imam is like so I think the question is
wanted me to explain how the top model
works in general right so think about a
basic air be a model so they the basic
air the a model that I just talked about
in the very beginning so they're really
works it's like basically your assume
that the same say two words tend to
occur very together so you know in the
same document so say a and B occurs in
this document and a and B occurred in
our document and then you know a NSE
occur in our document and I'm not
exactly you know so here's how it works
basically say let's say I we have two
topics then we say a B occurs in lots of
documents an AC occur in another set a
lot of documents so basically if you
were create a to top you model it turns
with separate a B as a topic and AC as a
topic so that when you actually try to
estimate the probability of these
observations that turn to give you a
higher probability so if you just give
ABC as a single topic it's in there
would be lower probabilities because ABC
you know they don't usually occur
together and that's the basic intuition
there but there there are some other
mathematical details that I actually
make this happen
that's right yeah yeah yeah but maybe
Hemmer also occur be some otter you know
contacts that that may you create a
separate topic for hammer yeah so so
basically so in this case is like this
a.m. paper use lots of words from
Statistics so but they don't use many
words about computer vision for example
they never mention an image in this
paper so emphatically you don't really
see like a topic about communication
that will be assigned to this particular
but your document
however like you know as more and more
people read this paper if it seems that
this paper is also very useful in the
context of computer vision so how do we
interpret this behavior because maybe
because this paper is a useful technique
that can be used in lots of light can be
the recent models so then this time user
behaviors change the way we should look
at this paper out of this paper is not
about communication but maybe you know
when we consider be some recommendations
we should recommend this paper to commit
a recent people because the technique
presentes paper is useful in that area
but that that doesn't say that our
sister his papers are important to
recent people because maybe there's
another statistic APA paper use kind of
like similar words at this paper but
idea present present in that paper it's
not really generalizable so maybe it you
know probably that's good within this
community but it's not a very popular
you know outside your communities so
this has a usual behavior reading
behavior tells us how these papers you
know or articles behave you know outside
their own particular topics or within
their own topics so I would give some
examples how that works so now we you
know that's the basic idea for
collaborative model actually pretty
simple
so given this you see behavior we want
to do some analysis so that we can you
know recommend this
paper to both test people city or
animation people so how do we do that
it's actually pretty simple combination
so remember that we use this copy
proportions to represent documents so
that's the basic of a topic model and
then we then we add one thing we have we
call a correction vector to this
document to this copy of proportions
that we think we you know account for
the behavior users then we use this
sound vector as the point of
representation for you know one for the
users okay there so for example in first
of some very popular or maybe very
popular documents if it's popular also
outside their own field you may see a
you know big correction vector sorry
about it keeps coming why with seems
like in my computer so if it's a very
popular outside their own particular
topic
you may see a big correction to account
for that but for some other very popular
articles but if it's only within their
own particular topic there won't you
want to see actually big correction
factor although the user behavior
kind of tell you that you should you
know do this particular topic but
because it's already within your content
information there's no need added
correction okay so here is the model
it's a little bit more it's really in
what but the basic idea is on the top is
a topic model we saw in the very
beginning and on the bottom is actually
have kind of a simple matrix
factorization model to do recommendation
okay hello to work anyway so I just
speak aloud maybe um so basically this
model we just work like this your oh
thank you um oh it's like oh hello okay
good so that how they said copy model
and the bottom is a
may take a factor outdated model anyway
hello okay anyway so um so the bottom is
an amazing Sakura decent model the way
we connect these two models is it's
medically worse I think it's is actually
use a correction vector to connect the
tapia proportions and the user under the
the article preference which I didn't
and so here unfortunately
so this is a model that we we sorry
hello this is a model that we presented
in the kdd turn 11 but recently there is
a new model which is actually although
the user they are they use the almost
the same graphical model but they have a
much better like a formulation of the
system idea so the question vector is
it's like you know this weird sometime
work something not kind of challenging
for me because it makes me like - let
adapt to my own Moy so this thing okay
so the correction factor works like this
suppose that we run a topic model on a
set of documents without use that
behavior then we get a top-tier
proportion which is stated there that we
you say that we represent a topic
proportions and so how do we that get
this counter correction vectors so if we
use this copy proportions to do
recommendations sometimes we make it low
very low we're very bad you know results
for example and let's say for example if
we observe say this article is actually
read that many can be the recent
researchers but if we only use is copy
proportions
we won't make that happen because if we
only look at the content of this this
this you know this document will be only
can because only
recommended to statistic people so how
do we make the this you know this paper
also appealing to recent people so that
correction vector actually place
although here is actually artificially
add a vision happy to this document and
we use this combined representation
which is on the right hand side to do
recommendations so that basically the
you know you the use of behavior tells
us which sudha correct this document so
it has more topic
topics than it has in this document
that's that's we call it extraction
vector here
okay so here's some experiments that we
won so they have a two datasets
one is that you like is to be small and
the monthly data is kind of large but
maybe it's small you know in today's
vendors deal like that's not really tell
me so okay so we do to type
recommendations and so the way the
reason we do it is we also separate to
two scenarios so that we can do a fair
comparison so the first type of
recommendation is we call email face
prediction basically we observe and user
and article matrix and all the articles
in this matrix have at least read by 101
users in the second type of
recommendation we count of automated
prediction basically you got some like
completely new articles you know maybe
this post on archive or just published
then you don't have any user information
about those articles you know you don't
know who is going to read this you know
you don't know who has read this article
okay so those are two type
recommendations so we you know so this
are the results we have two data sets at
Empire with two baselines baseline model
is one baseline model is they are da
model which is you know we don't use the
usage behavior we just use the copy
proportion to the recommendation and
then the next page run is MF is a
maitreya factorization model we we don't
use tax for any information we just use
simply a user item matrix nice the
general like mystery of higher ed listen
for recommend it and does then we
compare with these two models just make
this to you know point out is like four
out of major prediction you don't have
this Xfinity bye-bye
so I don't have those making a
factorization for the ultimate
prediction because those new documents
you don't have any user and user like
information so there's no way to make a
prediction on that in that setting
but anyway so so the imagery prediction
we see that our model for the use bows
to the information from a documents and
the the users information can perform
the best comparable to our model compare
better than our tomorrow's this is on a
first dataset so here on the second
dataset which is on Monday data set so
again this model is the sort of the best
model but you can see that there is
actually flipping between on the left
hand side the flipping between the blue
curve and the green curve so the reason
is because this multi data is there are
just so many documents in this data set
but the user information actually kind
of sparked so it kind of really realized
more tax free information to make a
recommendation
that's right yeah it's it's almost like
a the same yeah because you don't have
you don't use your newest information in
that setting okay so so we could we
could you know end in here
you know we've we've proposed a new
model to do some recommendations we get
some better results so I can pop it's a
paper um that could be something like
that but you know at the very beginning
we I said like the target model actually
provides some kind of ways to organize
your data to discover hidden patterns so
you know which so we don't really want
to stop there okay
good question yes so the magnetic data
is a lot larger
so yeah contains a lot more documents so
yeah ceremony and this is like a site
like is it kind of small data set and
also the sparsity it's a lot more sparse
than the satellite data
partly because maybe because the manatee
was found in later than the cycle like
say they don't have that user base maybe
they have it right now probably get
better results
yes sister yeah so there were some
examples
I think we're possibly under that
question if they're still not clear I
probably give you more information
okay so so here's an article with the
saw you know maybe it was such a few
times I think in this talk okay so here
is the actual topic proportion for this
document from that dataset society like
data set for example it has a very high
copy proportion for two for sorry hello
for you know parameter estimation and hi
seekers somehow a little bit lower per
copy proportion for our returns
optimization that's actually the topics
for this document if you run in basic
FDA model it would be similar like this
but if we actually add the user
information if I use our model to
actually generate that happy proportions
for this document that you guys can see
the corrections that we add to this
document basically those those blue
topics it seems to the petition I hold
it so those blue topics actually those
like Corrections we add to this document
basically it says that this document is
not about the Bayesian if you read this
paper you know this paper is nothing
about Bayesian there's no single basic
word
there's no posterior whatsoever so but
if people read this paper you know put
people you know who like a Bayesian
method also you know read its paper
because the idea in this paper actually
generalizable through lots of different
models including basic models so that's
what God is tougher proportions that I
corrected or added to this particular
document I'm not sure that that's answer
your question so the idea is so this
copy proportion was you know but trained
you to by the use of behavior they're
adding more topics or maybe sometimes
not anymore even so here is not an
example
this is example shows that it does not
really add anything new to this
particular document this document is
basic about that particular topic that
you know the words that card in red but
even you you know you know we we have
lots of users that you know read this
document but you don't see much
correction you're maybe it says the only
thing you see is there's a scale change
for for this for this one existing topic
the reason is there is some like a
skinny factor for ratings so you know
the model that I mentioned here the
bottom model actually I think it fixed
that okay so there's some more thing we
can do with the result so giving this
model we can actually look at you know
the posterior estimate or whatever the
the parameter estimates we we can find a
widely read article in the field our
kind of find articles that have you know
why they read in our reviews there's
third thing we can do is we can find my
articles from RFU's than a widely read
in this field so here's a magnitude
example so there is a particular topic
about like maximum likelihood basic
parameter estimation of using maximum
likelihood and then you can you can use
these results to actually discover those
articles like this so the read article
is basically it's about this topic but
also very popular in this topic
basically means these articles are very
popular in this area and it's the the
blue articles are kind of like it's also
about this topic but also very popular
in other views so this article is kind
of like I have a more influence in other
fields as well because maybe the idea in
there it's so useful or maybe for some
other reasons so the last the last three
articles is not about this topic they
don't really talk about parameter
estimate in their these papers but is
actually popular in this area because
you know
this idea is maybe useful in this area
as well so you know this sort of thing
you can discover from this results
there's not any down hole the network's
he's about network science sorry and
it's about the similar type of results
you can find is the you know the right
articles about its topic but also
poverty in this topic but basically it
tells you that you can use this results
they were useless moderate Muslim is
also have to find the particular like
aspect that is kind of like a different
for this article from our articles
basically these are Street everything
you can do I mean I can vary there may
be snorting and do with this result but
but this the thing is kinda like a the
immediate thing can do okay so I'm still
talking about like this the
collaborative topic models so we have a
reason to have a paper about kind of
similar idea but to analyze a different
type of data is to analyze the there's
like a network data for example this is
a based on this English Wikipedia data
the the idea is say you analyze the data
you see a topic model but how about we
can see there are the links between
links between these articles so we can
think of like the links as kind of like
a readership for example if I link to
you then I kind of like likely you some
way I want to read you or maybe some we
have some kind of like you know
relations you know mongers so and that
kind of like the information we see in
the collaborate topic models that like
the users so basically we hope that you
find a similar effect in this cat hype
of data you know so that we can use the
similar correction idea in this network
data it turns out it's kind of like a
pretty similar findings so that you know
the topics within the documents that can
be corrected by the links information so
I would think there may be summary
information can be used in
similar way so that when you you know
try to analyze your document collections
you need when you have like extra
information or kind of like user
behavior or kind of like you know this
my information explain how this document
could actually shift from its original
meanings so thanks to the basic I think
it's take-home message about this model
is basically when you analyze a document
you know some other information may
actually affect the way you should look
at its data okay so the summary of this
model is like I think three things it's
actually blend content based and a
rating based recommendation into a
single model and can be used to discover
patterns in how people read and a hot
dog when I read and it can suggest the
new ways we're doing doctor
recommendations so I here's a new way
yeah macerate quite new but let me just
do a demo here um yeah weird
you didn't really describe the correct
resolution um can make it better okay
cool okay so this is a recommender
system for scientific articles this
interface user interface I think is
pretty bad but because I didn't really
spend time on it so so here is the panel
is basically suppose you are one of the
users and this is a user ID you know
33:11 then I want to you know say so me
like ten recommend the articles so why
she does it's like Derek this is a user
panel and then this there's this panel
is this the user interest panel what it
does it's like you represent the user
interest using the topic models well it
does it like this so so these are the
weights these are higher weights about
meaning this user but you know user 3311
it's very interest in this particular
topic it's about the Machine the
classifier type of thing and also it
kind of interests in this online
classification of digital libraries
whatsoever and then the less interest in
our topics
so and here are some recommendations
like hopes I hope it's the last one I
think so what it does it's like giving
you some recommendations based on this
user interest so as you can see that you
know this is about the classification
article basically the how-to how do you
combine label data with unlabeled data
you need some are rhythm called code
training he's being a holly tree
classifier using unlabeled data this I
don't think he works now because I don't
have that's not really gonna do yeah so
so and then these are the actual
articles in his library so I grabbed it
from the satellite data so for this
particular user so one nice thing about
visualize is interest is like this so
you can do is for example today I just
don't maybe this topic is not very
popular anymore nobody wanted screen
cuts fair anymore so let's just forget
about it and then we can actually turn
it off and then actually you can run
some online recommendation so that when
you can or use some interactions with
this interest you know kind of like this
topic that you are no longer interested
in but you can also can put you know
it's sort like a take you know take
consider take a kind of like the rest of
it interest into the account to make
recommendations for example because you
know for examine you don't really want
to learn classifier anymore but you do
there's some other things you maybe want
into the you know we don't really given
the rest of your interest for example
maybe you know suppose this is something
you want to do now this is about like
you know the last topic is about like
it's about like you know there's a in
the bioinformatics there's quite a bit
literature about how to do like data
mining to find efficient ways of like
doing some of my DNA stuff remember
exactly those things but there's entire
districts are about like using text
mining algorithms to like a berry
information discovery so suppose that
you know you want to learn some
about that you know you can actually
turn it on so what it actually does is
actually you know consider this a new
topic but also consider your existing
interest so that sort like make this
transition a little bit smooth so that
you don't really bump into something
that completely new so this actually saw
like a make this transit maybe a little
bit better for some of you some of the
users so here is basically the you know
the some simple thing you can do for
recommend recommending like a like like
documents this is a clapper topic model
but I think there might be something new
for you know small routine can do but I
don't really have time to you know
implement those things yeah so okay so I
think that's it so you know there's a
very last thing is you know I'm just
joined by the air lab so you from
usually in join there let me know you
know we hurry also thing those people go
I think so yeah it could be yeah
yes yes yeah I think so yeah that's good
actually good um good thing to mention
yeah
so um so here this is an example like
you're using and to apply the same idea
into a network data but I think if there
is some kind of our information that you
know like maybe you could have a count
type of thing that maybe this guy fork
that account but you know when you
analyze they're you know they're Owen
like personal like repositories you kind
of analyze you know how wide it fork is
like is this kind of like a particular
information you're right yeah that's
yeah that's right yeah yeah that's right
yeah I think is this kind of go beyond
this particular data data set but
exactly how we do that um I'm not sure
yet
yeah that's good question yes so so
those are kind of like a addition of
like a metadata information but
unfortunately this puts you're a model
but you know we do have region usually
use it but I think those are actually
very useful and you actually make
recommendations there might be kind of
way that you want to incorporate in this
model you know in some way so that
they're actually useful for making
recommend for example maybe you know in
this particular model you can actually
model the user in some way that actually
consider those metadata just for example
like it very very very very dumb model
is like okay so let's just use user
preference and then concatenate a like a
existing features as another you know
like like a type of like information and
that's basically thing you can do but I
think you can definitely go beyond on
that
that's a very good question yeah so I
think there is thing the best way of
probably just in this model particular
model we did with like cross validation
because we do have a like so I go with
data set for recommendation like top 10
I think we use top 5 recall here I think
I remember your top top maybe top 5 out
of 10 remember exactly then we say
basically we use a cross validation to
actually you know take the certainly the
best number of topics and the best
parameters for for this particular model
but in general that's a very hard
problem for running a topic model it's
like there's not a really good way
the selecting a number of topics yeah
but that's right
homina copies
yeah yes that's right yes so so in this
pursuit is that you can you know for
approximate documents you can have like
maybe hundreds the topics actually
capture the entire corpus for one
particular document usually it's a bit
sparse so usually a document does not
have too many dark too many topics but
that's basically in a per assumption of
a topic model you you actually want you
know fewer topics for particular
document if a document contains too many
topics it probably not a good good
document you know it just covers too
much I don't know what
so for example like because here is one
example
um okay sorry there's no example here
okay so um so here this is a particular
document about that um paper we talked
about and there in this particular
document collection we actually run a
500 topic model which is actually on the
right end of access access so what I
feel I've seen is lots of the topics
actually they're off you know basically
they don't have any information in this
document and those estimated Taavi
proportions actually represent the
topics in this document basically you
know you see these red bars actually
that the topic is actually mentioned in
this document that's how it decided it
decided by the by the inference process
like a you know you you basically you
have some comment section some data and
then when you model and those are all
like determined
um yeah that's good question yeah um I
think there is there are a lot of like
visualizations like a can be you know
based on topic modeling so in for
example you want to discard there is
nothing to use in this like network
domain to analyze my quadriceps quarters
like find the communities that I
mentioned in the beginning so and also
people use it for doing like gene
discovery to find correlations so and
also you people we also use it for some
others as the discoveries like car
proportions as features as some kind of
like maybe some future prediction tasks
so usually it's not very yeah you can be
used for classification but usually the
experience is like it usually is not
very good just for classification you
can easily use this as features use does
not return to from worse than a like a
purely discriminate is from algorithms
so so so one thing you can do is you
know use the additional additional
features if you just want a classifier I
wouldn't recommend use this so so
basically if you if you just want to are
doing a classifier then you probably
want one one of you so you know like
find the communities yeah so doing gene
discoveries correlation of genes yeah so
those four things oh yeah and there was
a lot of like visualizations I think
there was some like a firms used it some
ideas to find patent correlations so I
think my adviser is doing some kind of
selling to those companies but like
exactly Holly do it I'm not sure but
there might be some use cases like this
I think one thing is I heard from him is
they actually use this term algorithms
actually reduce the Hmong of like a you
know a work of lawyers to a substantial
amount of time to those things yeah I
don't know yeah I don't know either
but those store like of use cases here
so basically it's like you want to you
can just never like it you want to do
something like export or not a face
those are the the applications the top
model will work the best okay that's it